radon is in the same group as helium and
the other noble gases is in the highly
unreactive material however radon has
quite an importance because it is formed
by the decompensated decomposition of
some other elements as I mentioned what
you can imagine radioactivity as a
droplet of water splitting into two and
they don't have to split into equal
halves and you can quite often be left
with radon now if you live in areas of
the world where there is radioactive
material in those minerals in the ground
then radon as gas which is quite
long-lived
can come up through the ground and
accumulate in your house and then if you
breathe it in in principle it can cause
lung cancer and so there are some parts
of the UK where radon levels are much
higher than others particularly those
areas that are based on granite but it's
very unpredictable because if there
happens to be crack in the rocks under
your house you can get more radon than
the guy next door and so there has from
time to time being a lot of worried
about radon in the air but for most
people is not something that you should
really worry about